this is a production of Cornell
University
well we collectively have put together a
presentation we felt that it was a
worthy topic to talk about distance
education in the department because it
exists in some pockets among a number of
us but it hasn't really been elevated to
a department-wide conversation it also
seems as if it's sort of can fall
through the cracks a little bit between
teaching and extension and what our hope
is that today will each be presenting
what we do which you know for each of us
is a little bit different try to keep it
to just you know five to seven minutes
of peace and and then open it up for
discussion I see that we don't have a
lot of faculty with us here today we
have some you know some of us but we
have a lot of students and you know
maybe we can capture both perspectives
in terms of what questions you might
have as faculty members about where you
might go with this as students do you
see a need that isn't being met that
could be met through a distance
education course and that sort of thing
anything else you want to add before I
jump in ok so I'll jump right in I'm my
name is Marsha M chiefly and I teach
several courses in the department and
also and one of the co program leaders
for Cornell garden based learning and I
teach a number of courses distance
courses through the Moodle interface
Moodle is an online distance learning
software and I actually really like I'm
not I'm not technologically savvy Nora
my phobic I think I sit somewhere in the
middle and I found it to be really nice
to work with I initially began with some
botanical illustration courses because I
saw an opportunity and wondered if
online learning might be even better
because in learning illustration at home
step-by-step maybe people wouldn't be as
self-conscious as they often are in the
classroom and in fact that's
the case it's been really successful I
have in my view I've really enjoyed
doing it maybe I should say and the
students seem to respond to it and since
then I've developed these first two
courses working on this should say
botanical illustration three advanced
techniques we've completed that this
summer and we're pilot testing it an
introduction to garden design course of
foundations of global garden based
learning course I wasn't all that happy
with and I still have it but from that
one of our County educators modified it
to become teaching and learning in the
school garden and she teaches it now
primarily this has been a New York State
audience but we're launching it
nationally this fall and these courses
have had students from all over the
world Pakistan Saudi Arabia Thailand
Japan Australia New Zealand Dominican
Republic Costa Rica literally an
international audience all the classes
that I teach offer what I think of as
these essential elements reading and
resources exercises and assignments to
scan and upload with individualized
feedback about their progress a student
forum to engage with others and then
considerable reflective writing so that
they can process what they're learning
how they're learning it and any barriers
to that learning that may be taking
place I'm just as just a snot snapshot
of the working with watercolor course
just to give you a visual image of what
the Moodle interface looks like you can
see that these buttons over here are
things
click on this little square is an
interactive they first they practice
scanning and uploading an assignment
their first week many of my students
have never taken a distance learning
course and they say it's almost like two
and one they're learning the content and
they're also learning how to learn at a
distance here's a snapshot from the
teaching and learning and the school
garden course looks a little bit
different visually but it's the same
general idea you can see they're
submitting a portfolio project here and
doing a lot of program planning a lot of
engagement with others along the way so
some consistent themes that I've seen
before I closed my portion of this
seminar it is a continued among students
amazement at the ability to form a
genuine community at a distance I was
surprised that you could really do that
I mean I was a little skeptical I was
convinced that there was worth and
teaching coursework but I didn't know if
you could really get to know people and
it's amazing the degree to which you can
form a community somehow you managed to
connect with me and my classmates
despite the distance and hardware turned
a computer into experience into a
classroom experience as intimate and as
personal as a classroom with walls and
this was an educator who taught for 35
years and she was delightfully surprised
as well so that's a consistent theme in
the botanical illustration courses I
would say a consistent theme is it's not
about drawing it's learning to observe
the plant world people are learning as
much about the plants as they are
learning to draw them this learning to
see notion
comes up again and again from this I
learned to look at everything in a new
and more focused light to slow down and
slowing down helps with my sense of
direction and proportions so that is
something I hear from I would say of the
vast majority of students and this
student happened to include a lovely
quote that I wasn't familiar with and
thought summarized very well there
they're learning in this in this manner
and I feel as if I ought to do a truth
and advertising thing here they also
learn to draw in the botanical
illustration courses they it's amazing
that they can do that in six short weeks
that they can go from not really knowing
how to producing some pretty stellar
work my son actually asked me when I was
talking about this yeah but let me see a
before shot so I felt you might want it
to here's a little leaf drawing here in
the upper corner just three ginkgo
leaves and this person produced this in
the fifth week of the course so you
progress in a very specific way you do
it every day and just like learning to
play the piano you do in fact move along
here's here's somebody this summer at
the end of the watercolor course and
I'll tell you I'll be I will admit I
feel as if she surpassed me and her
skill and then lastly the experience I
feel as if it's worth talking about the
opportunity here for engaging students
as TAS for the first time this past
spring and teaching the intro to garden
design class I worked with a landscape
architecture graduate student who
co-taught along with me and just sent
this a couple weeks ago after about 3-4
weeks ago after returning from an
internship he felt like that experience
was the thing that got him his job over
this
they saw that teaching on his resume and
felt that he was the superior candidate
so I think there's a huge opportunity
for engaging students in this process
too hi everyone my name is Erica Renee
and I work for the Cornell small farms
program based here in the heart
Department hopefully you all have heard
of us and you're all welcome to stop by
anytime we're down in the basement in
15a and 15b and my part of the small
farms program is that I co-managed the
northeast beginning farmer project which
we began in 2006 I think it was because
we were hearing from a lot of our
partners in county extension office's
that they were getting contacted by
people interested in starting a farm and
a lot of the offices didn't feel that
they had good reef resources to send to
these people and pretty quickly as we
got into we assemble the leadership team
of extension educators to work with us
and determine what we could do as a team
through the small farms program to try
to meet some of the need and provide
information to people wanting to get
started in farming and it pretty quickly
emerged that having an online course
might be a good thing to try out we knew
that there are already people like Ken
and Marguerite and Marsha and Lori doing
this kind of work in the department's we
knew the infrastructure was there our
target audience is scattered all over
the place geographically they tend to be
people who have other jobs you know
mortgage kids a house stuff like that so
they can't necessarily learn about
farming in some of the time-tested ways
like going and working on someone's farm
full-time for a summer or something like
that they tend to be people who are
looking online for resources so they're
relatively internet savvy and these are
generally not people who want to just
gardener homestead we're looking at
people who are wanting to start a
commercial business farming so we
thought it seems like a good thing to
try out we also observed that this these
are people who can google their way to
piles of information
I mean it wasn't actually information
that there was a shortage of it was more
like guidance in how to use all of that
information how to put together a farm
plan and things like that and we decided
that if we were going to try out these
online courses we wanted to be able to
do it as something that didn't require
constant grant input in order to make it
work so we've been attempting to run
them in a way that they are self-funding
basically over time and we also have
learned that it's really important that
we incorporate we can't just have
extension folks teaching the courses
that we need to incorporate the voices
of successful farmers into intercourses
so in 2007 we tried out our very first
course and we just called it BF 101
beginning farming 101 and it we put
together the curriculum for it we looked
at a whole bunch of curricula that have
been used for classroom-based you know
introductions to farming and they all
tended to cover similar things some goal
setting assessing your resources but you
know looking at the feasibility of your
ideas from a market perspective and
profitability and so we trialed one
course that was nine weeks long and it
was so popular I mean I think we just
send out one single press release about
it and we could have filled the course
two or three times over just from that
one press release and we sent it
primarily to an audience our contact
list is primarily new york-based and it
got forwarded all over the country and
we were getting contacts from Canada and
all over and we thought okay well it
seems like maybe we've hit a nerve here
maybe this is something that we could
you know keep keep building on and so
now four years later we're up to 13
courses which is feeling up to be honest
a little overwhelming at the moment we
were running seven simultaneously for
the first time beginning this fall I
don't do much of the teaching i'm i am
co-teaching one this fall and business
planning but for the most part we have a
core team of extension educators who
have recruited and trained with help
from Paul Treadwell a group of
instructors and generally we have two
people instructed each course so that
they can share the responsibility and
that the people in the course have the
benefit of two different perspectives
and our courses we now have planning
things like BF 101 is still there we've
renamed it it's called square one now
and that's our most basic overview type
course for people who are really just at
the exploring and aspiring stage and
then all the way up to a planning course
that helps people write their business
plan and then we've in the last year or
so we've logged some production based
courses on poultry farming veggie
farming soil health things like that
more on the how-to side so I mentioned
that we have a core team of extension
educators and me and we're we're sort of
the team that hi that maintains the
vision for all of the courses and
recruits the new instructors and deals
with training and consistency of quality
of what we offer we now have farmers
teaching some of our courses they're
generally paired with a Cooperative
Extension educator when they teach but
the participants really strongly respond
with positive feedback that they love
hearing from farmers and so even when we
don't have a farmer who's teaching the
whole course we use webinars to bring in
farmer voices and so we'll bring in
webinars for each of the courses and
have farmers talk about their operations
I'll talk about that a little bit more
in just a minute so I kind of deal with
the overall logistics of the scheduling
and communicating with all the
instructors and we charge 175 dollars
per course and they're about six weeks
we are trying to balance I mean I think
that's a pretty good value people get a
lot for that amount of money would be
nice we some of the other online courses
in the department charge more but we
didn't want to price people who are
you know people who are in our audience
we didn't want to price them out so we
are looking at the possibility of being
able to offer scholarships in the future
but basically we use Moodle also just
like Marcia was talking about and this
is a little snapshot of what what of
course looks like so this is kind of the
stuff that you might find at the very
top of every course and it has some
welcome a forum where people can
introduce themselves a little bit of
orientation to what it's like to learn
online what Moodle is how to use Moodle
and then in each week there will be
readings discussion forums homework
assignments and then the schedule for
the webinars or the recordings and if
people miss webinars we always record
them so they can watch them later now
our courses aren't standalone just in
Moodle though we integrate a few other
resources so the I mentioned that this
is part of the Northeast beginning
farmer project the online courses are a
really big chunk of what we do they're
not the only thing we do but this this
is the website for the Northeast
beginning farmer project and it's its
sister website is the small farms
program website we kind of treat this
website more or less like a textbook or
a you know sort of a companion text
Moodle is sort of like the classroom and
so is Adobe Connect which we use for
webinars and this is more like a
textbook and within this website if you
click on this box here it takes you to
the new farmer hub and that's really
where the textbook is so we have this
green box shows you a list of tutorials
which have worksheets embedded in them
videos frequently asked questions and
anybody could go to our website and
access
this information but the value that they
get and being part of the online course
is that they have a cohort of learners
and like Marcia was saying it feels like
you form a sense of community even
though the people often never meet each
other in person they form the sense of
community they get to hear from their
fellow learners what their plans look
like they get to get feedback on their
own plans so and they can ask directly
ask their instructors questions so it
just is a lot more of a dynamic learning
experience than just you know working
your way through the website but
certainly anyone who is self-motivated
could just work their way through this
planning process we also integrate
videos that are on the website we have
an entire video gallery and that video
gallery is growing at a rate of a few
Clips a month at the moment we have we
started with some business oriented
business clips we interviewed farmers
all over the state talking about how
they got started with their farm and now
we've expanded it and are doing more
like how two kinds of videos the
webinars I mentioned we originally did
not include in the course but one
instructor wanted to include one webinar
and then at the end of the course the
feedback they got was that that was the
absolute favorite part of the course
people loved getting together in real
time they loved hearing from farmers
they loved learning about other
resources and just having the
opportunity to interact in real time so
the webinars are now a feature of all of
our courses in pretty much once per week
we do
so from last fall through this past
spring we had 150 people go through
courses and the impacts very and we're
we're also working on trying to do a
better job of capturing numbers related
to the impacts but people recorded
things like increased confidence new
funding better planning securing farm
mentors and increased profitability we
try to make sure this was easier
initially we limited the courses to just
New York participants because our very
first course development was funded by
the New York farm viability Institute
now we have some funding for nucleus we
do take we do have grant funding often
for development of new courses but once
a course is developed we expect it to
run without extra outside funding and we
have expanded because we have so many
courses now in order to make it viable
to charge money and run the course is
just based on revenue we allow people
from all over the place to take the
courses so we've had people from Africa
and Brazil and Canada and all over the
place take them and that has made it a
little bit more challenging to try to
connect people with their local
resources after the course so in the
beginning we felt like it was so
important to make sure that people knew
who their local extension person was
knew who their was on the ground after
this six-week course who could help them
continue their learning and that part of
it has gotten a lot more challenging for
us as we've grown but we have some nice
quotes from folks who have taken the
course you know that it's a reasonable
price there again there's a ton of
information online but it's been really
helpful to hear from other people in the
class and certainly you know you can't
expect a six week class to give you
everything that you need to be able to
start a farm but this was a good
starting point
said one person in our BF 101 course and
then this person kind of taking that
romantic idea of oh I think maybe
someday I want to be a farmer and this
course really helped them to get drill
down into some of the specifics of
varieties site design Finger Lakes
climate and this person doesn't know
what their path forward will be but they
have a better understanding of the time
and expense involved which is really
important we try to help people avoid
train wrecks too so we counted as a
success if somebody takes one of our
courses and decides not to start a farm
too and I'm going to turn it over to
Lori now I'm Laura Bush way as I'm also
in the garden based learning program and
Marsha focus on youth development and I
focus more on two families and adult
education and and I am spent all of my
time in Cooperative Extension and I
realize we keep saying that I don't know
if everybody knows what Cooperative
Extension is and so I'm just going to do
a little primer on that so I as a
100-percent Cooperative Extension there
within cornell university we have county
association offices in each county or
associated any not necessarily in each
county but each county has a office a
local office they might be shared with
two counties and so there are county
educators as erica mentioned working
with local growers green industry the
general public in those county offices
and then those County educators connect
with campus experts research in other
programs to deliver research-based
information throughout New York State so
that's a little background on Cornell
Cooperative Extension so one of our
challenges with having County educators
connect with campus experts and research
that's going on in campus is that it may
require travel to campus or or those
count campus experts traveling to
counties and time for travel and funds
for travel has been decreasing so
alternative we decided to try was to use
webinars to actually connect
with campus experts via these webinars
and so that was really what started us
on this path of doing webinars was just
the practicality of using that to help
County educators connect with campus
folks and vice versa and so actually
it's Cornell Cooperative Extension that
maintains our Adobe Connect and I just
wanted to really show you sir for more
the lodge istics behind it because it is
frankly easy to do in my opinion because
somebody else is taking care of the bulk
of the backend and we just go in here we
set up a meeting and jenny was actually
just last Monday and this two Monday's
Nina will be will be on so this was
actually September 19th last Monday we
we set up a webinar you just set up a
time frame and then this is actually
what the screen looks like when you're
in the webinar and so what we do is
faculty are actually sitting wherever
they want to sit in their front of their
computer with a headset and they upload
their PowerPoint and they're connecting
the way we set it up is we have them
connect with individual counties not
individuals so the counties are will
actually recruit people into their space
like you are here and will broadcast the
webinar to a County who has a projector
and is showing the this image right here
to a whole group of people and the the
one one of the reasons why this works
out really well for the county's is we
are linking many of these webinars with
Dec Department of Environmental
Conservation credits for pesticide
certifications so they have to get these
ongoing credits and so one way to draw
an audience in ters in is to offer them
these credits continuing education
credits and they can sit there and hear
the webinar and also earn Dec credits
and the local counties benefit in that
they charge people to come to these
webinars we don't have anything to do
with the funding collecting funds from
them we just broadcast it to them and
they decide how they collect the funds
from individual counties and so part of
the success i think is we we just have
the presentations are short we usually
have two presentations in the evening
that are roughly an hour each and then
and that's sort of the end of it but
what happens after in addition to the
live presentation which we can record in
Adobe Connect I can then take that
recording in Adobe Connect and I use
this Camtasia software because I don't
know anything else I'm also not very
tech savvy but I use its camp table
Camtasia software that is a screen
capture software to to take the
recording and then I move the recording
from from this space on to Vimeo so in
it and Vimeo is just an online place
where you can post videos and then
people can view them again so it's
rather a crude process but in addition
to the live webinar which they would get
DC credits for other people can go and
view the process after the fact the
webinar later on on vimeo so it's an
opportunity to capture people the first
time but also those who can't make
either county educators or the general
public can come and view it on vimeo at
a later point so a couple different
times and very different from the
six-week eight-week courses this is kind
of a small time frame to get a small
shot of some information that is within
the expertise within cornell and the
other thing i think that's oh well yeah
i just want to mention whether a thing
which this is allowed um sort of lead to
so once i got good at doing the webinars
and then doing the screen capture I
started to realize anytime anybody does
a presentation I can just capture
capture it on the screen and record it
and then post it and so for a Master
Gardener volunteer conference this past
year we had a couple of the
presentations we were just doing screen
captures while they were presenting to a
I've audience just like this we had no
other connection and we were able to
capture that presentation and then post
that 24 for later viewing by other
people who are interested in the topics
so yes good afternoon my name is Ken
logic any of you don't know me myself
and Marguerite wells we're going to talk
about two of the courses that we have
developed over the years we've actually
I think back in time this all started
about 1995 believe it or not with a
course called the hall and why of
grafting and then since then that is
evolved in new courses have come into
play what we want to talk about today
then is plant propagation one course
developed by myself and Marguerite and
organic gardening the other course
developed by margaret and charlie maza
these are courses that run for eight
weeks they are entirely asynchronous and
the target audience is typically we we
began all this thinking that we would be
the approaching serving amateur
gardeners and that's largely the case
but over the past several years we've
been getting more and more students who
are horticultural professionals or who
want to be people who are about to get
into the nursery industry or some other
horticultural profession we have over
the years had students from all over the
United States and some international
students as well so recover I mean
that's one of the things about distance
learning you're no longer restricted to
a particular geographic location in the
old days extension Cooperative Extension
ones
the single County but now we can go far
beyond that excuse me the plant
propagation course sorry plant
propagation course is taught once per
year so that meets the demand out and
organic gardening twice per year these
courses are limited to about 30 students
30 to 40 and we have we decided that
that's about as many as we could really
manage discussion discussion board is a
very important part of the course and
it's just difficult if not impossible to
maintain a really interactive discussion
if you get much beyond 30 or so so we
limit ourselves to those numbers and
it's also necessary since Marguerite is
such an important part of the course she
is actually the primary instructor for
both courses and I'm sort of the backup
guy but she doesn't work day to day and
she doesn't work for free so it's
necessary for these courses of bringing
enough income to the payer and that we
succeeded that very nicely at these
prices and we find plenty of people who
are willing to pay these prices now in
terms of the way we approach teaching
these courses just like the other
speakers we use the software removal
it's sort of like teaching for dummies I
mean it works out very well you don't
have to be tech-savvy as it has been
point it out there are three three parts
of it an online textbook by that I
simply mean text with pictures and links
to other websites basic information
provided that way but also the
discussion board that i just mentioned a
few minutes ago is extremely important
part of the course and we've gotten to
come up with ways very sort of labor
intensive ways and a part of the main
instructor to keep students involved too
as it was mentioned to develop a sense
of a community of learners and we do
this by or perhaps a less formal or less
structure than some of the other
approaches but we have a gimmick for
example called question of the day and
what we'll do is we'll throw up a
picture that has may have nothing to do
with the the assignment students just
read this week it might have something
to do with an older assignment or even
something come coming up and it's likely
to be something that most students have
run across now look at this and we ask
them what's going on in this turns out
to be burnout on Apple which is an
accumulation of adventitious roots it's
kind of a peculiar structure but it has
a great deal to do with the physiology
of roof formation of cuttings and other
things that's a lot of fun these
multicolored cactuses so those are both
propagation related issues we asked the
students just to react to them and
particularly something like that they
don't know though they'll try someone
answer or another they'll discuss it and
finally after a couple of days maybe
hone in on it on a decision and then
Marguerite will tell them whether
they're right or wrong and this is a
very important part the discussion
succeeds because we're involved that is
mostly her involved every day in that
discussion you don't just put out a
topic and and let it ride for a week you
have to be there constantly you're
answering questions from students but
you're also encouraging students to
interact with each other the shots on
the bottom are from the organic
gardening course pictures of the day and
the third major feature of these courses
and I think which is ever so important
to their success is that hands-on
learning is very very important I mean
after all horticulture involves hands-on
activities so every one of our courses
we have features that allows students to
learn by doing things and take grafting
for example which is one of the topics
covered in the plant propagation course
might look at me and say how you're
going to teach grafting by a computer
but what we do is we will send them a
lab kit this is only part of it but we
have these various supplies rooting
hormone and so forth and fine soil and
then what's not illustrated there is the
hibiscus plant that we sell them to not
sell them I mean yeah we saw we send
them to hibiscus plants that we've
raised in the greenhouse and there's a
video online that they can watch me some
years ago grafting that hibiscus and a
detailed a blow-by-blow summary of how
it works both in the text and the video
of me doing it and then they take those
hibiscus plants through the kitchen
table or wherever they're going to do
their grafting and they sit down and do
it and then immediately they start
interacting as far as I cut my finger or
or whatever worked or didn't work and
it's the whole activity not just the
activity but discussion generated by it
is I think very effective part of
learning this course the the lower left
the graph there is the result of a class
experiment we have them do this is a
seed germination experiment for the
plant propagation course each student
uses the seeds that we sent them to
compare different scare ification
treatments and they all send the results
in
and we put together as a as a graph a
composite of the whole class and this is
important i think because every time you
know there are few students may be a lot
of students for whom the experiment did
not work but by compiling it as a group
they can see oh yeah that's what was
supposed to happen and go on from there
that soil represents some of
Marguerite's hands-on activities for the
organic gardening course okay so
Margaret's going to take it over from
here and give you a live demonstration
of the organic gardening course now I
always make sure that the very first
week people introduce themselves so you
know Larry and Hollis and sandy can all
say hi and this is where I'm from and
this is what I do and I try to get a
little bit of personal detail out there
in that first week just so that people
can kind of chat and relate oh i
homeschool my kids to all I used to grow
up you know I grew up in Michigan also
where are you from it's not that it
takes over the course it pretty much
only happens in this one for them but to
kind of break the ice from a bunch of
strangers because as we've been all
talking how do you make a community out
of desperate people may not even all
live in the US its kind and it gives a
way of relating later and then the
question of the day stuff sometimes I
can start to scrounge towards the end of
the course if I've used up all my usual
demos and pictures but I try to have
like here's a link to a weed badger
which is a company that makes a weeding
tool for
show hey look at that so I have this
little video that they can link to and I
said okay what is this tool and why
would you use it or why would you not
use it where am I in cyberspace but
that's the kind of thing I do i link to
articles that I find on the web that you
know organic producer found in violation
of blah blah blah I try to talk about I
mean it is organic gardening not farming
but um but I do relate I try to educate
people what is organic anyway and why
are we getting at what's the difference
between farming and gardening and what
does it mean when something is called
certified organic because like I said
about a third of people in the course
are interested in maybe get starting
organic operations or they have some
sort of small thing or they're
interested in organic lawn care they're
already landscapers their customers are
demanding that they grow or that they
manage their loans organically and they
have no idea how so that's that's some
of the market that we try to serve you
know what's wrong with these seedlings I
how do you get more light how do you
know how much light is enough for
seedlings some of it is very basic
gardening information some of it some of
its fairly arcane stuff and we just try
to draw people that with the
conversation
so rioni I'm kind of done chalia forums
unless you guys have extra questions so
trippy yeah maybe that's why we have the
life giving this trend of it online
degrees what you thought the
processional was in the industry
I'm just thinking since you're asking a
question well there are multiple
responses it's a trend but they're
dangerous right that there are inherent
Canadians looking at one of the
action
program
graduate
maybe should
so I personally
one time i'm somewhat skeptical of the
actual chain
for your online
coming out
this is my personal skepticism very
and some
before
just to reinforce ballpoint my class of
this thing over here was in the infinite
times and Poland I don't necessarily
agree with it this fellow says that the
most i hope the sorts of change will be
distance learning its lower claws
effects flexibility ability to deliver
the nation's best faculty time talents
almost a we're now challenged the
traditional wisdom that you have to
spend years living in a college time to
get a great I thought I know what
anybody have a different point of view
well I just noticed that in the past
couple of years I did i get i have
gotten way more decrease or whether we
offer our courses for credit games then
I that I used to originally it was only
home gardeners generally 65 and older
they were very unsure about even how to
log into a website and they were
certainly not looking for
I you know I should go looking because
people are saying making you're
affirming somewhere else and I've looked
everybody else out there don't see one
of the dangers not to blow this
discussion way large one of the dangers
these people are
can't let distance learning out that
said well providing this
let the economics take over and push
people online
so that's one of these things really I
also say depends on the degree I mean
maybe computer programming can be done
by are the online but well cortical but
that's what horticulture is one program
I've not found anywhere I'll for dessert
just you know with your programs you
know how this associated there's no
credentialing process
we've already talked about how this is
linked to see credits this high
management education program would do
certification recertification credits in
dec approved three credit hour program
so it's not college classes are we
linking this crap eric are your courses
and Kendra courses but they link to
continuing education here where I'm
going to get your given our our courses
are not linked currently to the
continuing education because it hasn't
been nobody has asked us about that it
hasn't been
really but we have we are linked I
didn't mention that we're linked to the
Farm Service Agency so a lot of
beginning farmers like Farm Service
Agency as a branch of USDA and they have
loans that are really low interest at
specifically target beginning farmers
who meet certain criteria and often they
require those beginning farmers to have
financial or production-oriented what
they call borrower training credit and
so they had given us a certification for
all of our courses that we can provide
that credit
they do okay so that and that's
important we may use that in their
institutions for they may be doing this
credit they may use
go on some of them our educators remains
of
so now do you know Ron Gardner and Pema
okay so they've developed a bunch of
modules for recertification that are
actually valid through the Dec so we
went through this whole process of
negotiating with the DC how do you
evaluate learning online how do you know
what people actually reading the content
that they're supposed to be reading and
things like that so there are ways to
actually deliver certifications and
recertifications online it's a process
but then that to me is a little bit
different than I also know that our
courses have never done the continuing
anything although we've always thought
it was possible to go over and then
office of continuing in a given
individual accredited they wanted the
only people who have ended up wanting
anything are some teachers who wanted to
indicate to their their district to
their supervisor or whatever that they
spend a certain amount of time doing
something so i write them a letter say
yes Joe Smith spent 15 hours my online
course because i had a lot of that I can
tell that it wasn't just that the
computer was open to that page I could
tell they were actually interacting it's
kind of time
they spent 15 hours and these with
subjects be covered and you know I can
certify that and generally that's all I
needed was a little bit of info people
however we do give certificates of our
own they're just a certificate that i
made in PowerPoint right so that I
certified cookie ice cores and that
seems to satisfy those people and they
are pretty anxious to get the final
little slogan goes out the door where's
my certificate I not complete the course
adequately we like the same experience
right a good question yeah I'm sure they
answered me different British person
depending on the length of the course
but about how longs it take you to
develop of course the six or any week
course and how much time do you men who
spent each day supporting the forums and
word
I'll just say what's gotten easier
because what I often do is it's weird to
think that you can do
copy and paste and I right over the top
of it all
wooden documents
same parent in flavor
that take
I'd say an average of
the webinar I know
and played yourself yes yeah how many
people one they need a whole lot of
hand-holding and talking to everyone
else targeted with our online yes to the
I degree and then at the end of course
it's a lot fire basically is a huge
filter
drops off
do you find that all of the participants
you actually participate or there's a
handful of them like
workers yeah allow lurkers a handful of
yeah
we'll come to the courses with different
expectations so like you know we've
sometimes beat ourselves up over like
why aren't people interacting more in
every course berries like you're on the
same course two or three times and in 11
course the group of people will be so
chatty and the next time you run it it's
a really quiet group but you know
sometimes my more attrition or less
attrition and or more or less
participation do anything wrong and when
we talk to those people will find oh no
it's just that I'm not going to be
starting my farm for three years so I
just kind of wanted to take this course
just to like see what was out there and
they really have this kind of casual
approach to it and then other people are
writing their plan now they have a need
for information now and they're the ones
who are more
have to closing questions than there are
times I want to make sure the Geneva
books
share any questions that they may have
it also just get this
see any opportunities to augment your
education there are a module or
something
just making sure we are hitting everyone
in our
Jimmy bars
question how we've got a question I get
now we'll just make sure the role of
eCornell of any of the people in the
group spoke on the panel there anything
approach eat corn out in the past what
is he core knowledge is what I was a
distance learning program let me check
can I asked it your question be brought
to subscribe what video collaboration
services is period for now and what our
operations group faculty assistance
program offering
whatever that's yeah yeah gaze up and we
see that they talking to the panel here
that they've kind of craft in her own
thing to go was hard to discern here
what eagle or l is and all the other
possibility since that down so I come
from extension so we have the best
Pacific goal on a specific set of needs
Cornell is diversity has a lot of
different initiative going
the marriott community now eCornell my
understanding is it is a spin-off that's
a for profit manager to try to
and they have target markets that are
substantially different than our
audiences and are what their
participants so to clarify all of us
have used Moodle adobe connect through
Cornell Cooperative Extension they
maintain those resources for operative
extension we follow that point person
for us for all of us and Google we chose
to move because i Kenned original was
originally intended one of the
originator of this hole
blackboard but there were issues and
allow any external for distance
blackboard system there was no hood
system to allow our arguments are
participants across from your state the
univac passport
lady so that's when we started working
at Google and that's why we there on
install our own support structure for
that the same thing with Adobe Connect
we've been running connector five or six
years now first are winning connect the
invasion conversations
but while they're thinking about
thinking about who is your audience or
the scalpers connect our people
it was important for us to take action
on that so we install our own Kinect
system so we an extension have done some
things that ensure that our access is
continuously open and available
positions of the state whereas some the
initiatives going on Cornell are now
focused on that right
needs of students so our needs the verge
of it and it makes us horrible path and
summers now if CITS been looking at
Dakota me or wet web CT one of those who
are against us
we are more than happy to pull our our
webinar until they they catch up with us
we can't let our opportunities pass a
file relating for marketers organization
a movie so that is play some of the
divergences now I can't speak to all the
different do I campuses are working in
you different listen tech now babe airy
well they're doing the same thing pay
attention
it's computer I talked about earlier
last week they were actually promoting
see there's a new version or black
offers features that one of the things
that Google has is it's freeware
blackboard is expensive and can iowa
running a grafting course out of it and
years ago or whatever who's incredibly
clumsy to go between discussion boards
blackboard bugs yet was you know where
your content lives versus where your
discussion boards were and where your
assignments were just for sending people
to all these links all over the place
and logging in to different websites in
it was it was it was a first attempt but
it was not nearly as good as Moodle is
which is all in one place just login in
you're good to go I'm sorry say to me
and as a person who is very much
concerned with opening our access to the
system your actual tool that we use
or does not matter as much
orientation for inviting people and
so if something is the idea Cornell says
well blackboard is now accessible by the
citizens in the art I think we have any
problems looking at
transition over the ex are teaching in
that
no I might taste is we've all been using
these things and so we're comfortable in
them so if there are other people they
want to explore new things that would be
exciting and then to bring those to
those transfection them this does what
we needed to do but I don't think we're
not I don't see us venturing out it's a
tool for us not a way of life
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu